i gotta tell y'all i'm so excited to
talk to you about this wedding because i
was down a rabbit hole on instagram i
mean it just looked like an insane fairy
tale how does it feel married life a
couple weeks in it feels amazing i mean
we've been together for a while so
solidified it but
we've been in love and together and we
all already said it was going to be
forever so the paper and the big date
just made it perfect yeah i think it
just
celebrated that's all i was gonna say it
must feel good to be able to be
surrounded by so many loved ones but
also to look as fire as you did i mean
talk to me about the day what was it
like getting ready and um how did how
did you guys feel now when you're
looking back at it through photos you
know what do you remember most about
that big day
oh man i was so nervous and scared about
everything i was paced for
uh yeah a lot of things happened that
day as you can imagine it was so many
different moving parts and some things
were going wrong it seems like nothing
was going right i was crying and it
turned out to be a beautiful day i'm
still looking in pictures i'm probably
going to post pictures for the next
month because
yeah when i
heard i was trying to be very calm on
this day but when i saw her i could tell
that she wasn't ted i was like
first look and i i hadn't seen her all
day and i missed her and i just wanted
to hug her and kind of pat her down
because she was sweating she was nervous
i could see it so imagine having that
missing when you need that all day oh
god
isn't that so wild that that's how
weddings are everyone i talked to who's
gotten married says it's really
stressful and all of a sudden there's a
moment and i think it's usually after
the ceremony where you finally just can
exhale and and hopefully enjoy it so i
hope you guys got to enjoy it
i think we did i think i think for us it
was when we were kind of exchanging our
vows and looking at each other
it's like everybody disappeared yes and
then at the reception
when we did our first dance together oh
i don't see anybody else in there yeah
everybody wow that's magic what would
you say was the most emotional part of
the day was it the first look was it the
vowels was it that dance it was the
first look when
i turned around and saw her uh her
carriage she was riding in the horse and
carriage and i was like oh my god you
look so beautiful and they're pictures
that captured my face like
i think it was the both of us in that
moment because we had we hadn't seen
each other we tried our hardest to stay
away
finally got to see each other and then i
had i had never seen her in her dress
and she had never seen me in my dress so
that was our first look and then you
know it was like
it was like excuse my language [ __ ]
getting married right right
i do want to talk about the rings though
because i feel like fans are dying to
know about the rings and judy like when
did you know it was the right time to
propose so for me
we were
we were in a relationship and
um i was watching her just kind of hold
back herself and feeling like i don't
want to do this i don't want to be a
burden on you and so i felt like i
needed to do something to show her that
i accept her everything i accept flaws i
accept everything because that's how
she's accepted me i had started planning
it since like october before and my
birthday's in april so i've had rings in
the house hit me
for a month
brad what does it what does it feel like
to hear those words from judy you know
the fact that you know she's so
committed and wanted to make you make
sure that you knew that you know make
sure make sure that you know that you're
loved man are you kidding it made me
feel like the luckiest girl in the world
like girl where you been all my life
yes
i've seen heaven sent and she completes
me and i am so blessed to have her as my
wife now obviously you guys had uh quite
the affair you know like the wedding day
was epic but also so were the people
that were there how was the turn up is
what i wanted to know because you had
germain you pre there you had candy
burris and porsha we tried to make this
our moment yeah so
kind of we tried to to do the room but
we didn't even get a chance to do the
room yes we were trying to enjoy each
other yeah so i believe that from what
we saw in the pictures yes but we were
caught up in
you know like enjoying
yeah as you should be right as you
should be it did look like everyone had
a damn good time though
chance to eat really you didn't get a
chance to eat
no not really
i had a bite of a lobster tail
yeah
you know what that that tracks you know
it's a busy night for both y'all but
then that's why the honeymoon is so
special right because it's it's it's a
time for you guys to kind of just enjoy
each other without any of the other um
craziness around you so talk to me how
was the honeymoon well first of all i
didn't think we were going on a
honeymoon because we're so busy casuals
she's in the middle of putting out new
products and running her business i'm in
the middle of working on a new album so
we'll honeymoon later which is what i
thought then at the end of our reception
she stands up and she goes beautiful she
takes the mic i have an announcement to
make and i'm like oh god what is it
she's like we're going on our honeymoon
we leave tomorrow we're going to turks
and caicos and we're going for like
i was like
i was so excited oh my god wow
it was beautiful of course she's so
extra
she got like a seven bedroom villa we
had maids and chefs and it was we did we
went on a yacht it was it was the most
beautiful trip in the best ship of my
life and i
hated it judy you are full of surprises
that is you you you are uh hopeless
romantic
dynamic of our relationship i think she
she might have started it she might have
started it so now it's like it's like
it's it's a thing for us there's
absolutely nothing that she wouldn't do
for me and she's shown that she's shown
that she actually probably within the
first year she
i i've seen it it's are you okay do you
need anything are you okay doing
anything always trying to make sure
she's very accommodating and so why
would i like who would let that get away
huh especially when she's your twin
flame
guys have right guys have called each
other that you know your twin flame why
is that the best way to describe each
other
it is that's why we got married on 22 22
and it's actually tattooed on my back i
saw that like man and you got that this
past summer right yeah yeah our hearts
kind of mimic each other so
our our love language is a little bit
different but the way that we love
people the way that we care
is kind of the same so um
yeah that's why it is definitely us
twinning because she is no matter how
hard she is to y'all she is the most
nurturing loving anybody that's met her
that knows her knows her she's the most
nurturing loving person so your wedding
was obviously televised how did you guys
kind of come to that decision that you
wanted to air your wedding on tv we
debated about that we really debated
about that because we didn't want to
have to limit the attendees and um a lot
of her friends prop you know like it's
it's a thing having the camera's
following you know it's yeah for the
celebrity my celebrity friends you know
right so
side of it is we we gave our life to the
public so we said it it kind of would be
very selfish of us to kind of keep that
we have loyal fans and super fans and we
wanted to make sure they got a glimpse
and got to like share some of our joy
that's right you want to take them along
for the ride and the whole journey
because they've been there from the
beginning with y'all for sure so do we
so we will be able to get to see a lot
of behind the scenes stuff and maybe
even some of that stress that you were
talking about yes that was just
happening
like everything was happening we were
fussing and cussing and crying it was it
was a lot going on rat loves judy
right
exactly
and it is crazy it is crazy the best
part about it though i think is also
you'll have this forever almost as like
a video picture book you know of that
day like of course the stress happened
but that's not going to be the thing you
remember the most it's going to be my
wife it's going to be the setting all
the people that we love and care for
that genuinely care about us so you came
out in 2020 and here you are with the
love your life married you got a life i
mean i have to imagine that in the 90s
and the early 2000s it wasn't easy to
live authentically right so now that
you're on the other side of it how does
that make you feel especially knowing
that you're being celebrated for
being exactly who you are and loving who
you love the day we did it it felt like
a weight was listed i mean i was so
happy and
yeah
nervous after nervous
because the resp
people was all positive everybody you
got half the people saying girl we
already knew and then
oh my god i'm so glad you finally said
something and it is so great to be in
love and you look so happy you're
glowing and i just felt that it was
everything to me it's one of the best
moments of my life besides my wedding
that's right i'm so happy for you i mean
you mentioned you're working on an album
is this new era of life inspiring this
new music
oh yeah absolutely absolutely i cannot
wait for people to hear my new music my
new project is going to be awesome and i
haven't put out an album in so long
because it feels so different now
because i feel free and i'm happy
seriously
happy